bereits zu beginn der korona krise ende
märz 2020 wurde ein orf notfall studio
in der stiftskaserne in wien
eingerichtet
mit solchen ausweis studios soll vor
allem in krisenzeiten der sendebetrieb
von radio fernsehen und online
sichergestellt werden
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
macht sich in der
landesverteidigungsakademie in der
stiftskaserne persönlich ein bild von
der kooperation zwischen dem orf und dem
bundesheer gerade in krisenfällen ist
die information durch den orf
unabdingbar und daher bin ich sehr froh
dass nicht zuletzt aufgrund dieser
langjährigen auch partnerschaft mit dem
orf binnen kürzester zeit im märz damals
als das ansuchen seitens des
generaldirektors des orf kam unsere
verbindungsbeamten der
landesverteidigungsakademie diese sofort
auch umgesetzt haben ein studio das
vorbereitet für eine permanente
information der bevölkerung gerade in
krisenzeiten auch orf manager pius
strobl freut sich über die
zusammenarbeit mit dem bundesheer und
betont die bedeutung des notfalls
studios in der stiftskaserne ein guter
dessen dass wir den österreicherinnen
und österreichern zeigen aus dem
bundeskanzleramt das einen
pressekonferenzen von diversen
auftritten von politikern von geologen
wo sie immerhin der in der stadt dessen
in der stadt im zentrum stattfindet
viele tier seinen output von hier werden
die überspielung angemacht von ihrer
erfolgende zusammenschnitte kollegen
gestalten da die beiträge über spielen
sie kontakt elektronisch auf den
küniglberg und von dort in die
wohnzimmer der österreicherinnen